on en parle comme ça c'était passé la
semaine dernière tellement il y avait
deux choses à dire et à montrer et ce
matin encore on vous montre des images
on les voit moins on voit encore les
flammes sur le site de dieu ce
déraillement est encore un peu de fumée
le fait est qu'il ya plusieurs histoires
à suivre ici en ce moment il ya
évidemment le lieu de l'impact est temps
que les pompiers n'auront n'en n'auront
pas terminé avec tous ces wagons pour
vraiment sécurisés comme disent dans
leur jargon chaque wagon pour être
certain que ça n'explosera pas que ça ne
s'enflammera plus ils vont remettre
ensuite le site aux enquêteurs qu'ils
vont pouvoir faire leur travail et on va
pouvoir évoluer dans cette partie de
l'histoire mais pendant qu'on parle de
ça évidemment on suit aussi pendant
qu'on regarde ça on suit aussi tout ce
qui se passe en périphérie la périphérie
est large il a qu'à penser à l'accident
lui-même pourquoi un train vide qui
dévale comme ça la pente qui arrive qui
sont que les rails là il ya beaucoup à
dire mais pas vraiment rien d'officiel
être confirmé les enquêteurs travaillent
les propriétaires n'en disent pas
beaucoup et puis les faits sont pour
l'instant bien mince par rapport à ce
qu'on peut dire et on sait que comme
dans tous les accidents vie dans toutes
les catastrophes
c'est un enchevêtrement et nonchalant de
problème d'erreurs qui fait en sorte que
moment donné on arrive avec la
catastrophe et il ya les gens le monde
je vous le dis depuis hier matin la
difficulté la mer est directement nous
en parle
il ya des victimes on le sait il ya des
dizaines de victimes on le sait mais
combien dizaines de victimes quelles
victimes sont le sait pas il ya des gens
qu'ils savent il ya des gens qui savent
où étaient leurs proches leurs parents
leurs amis au moment ce s'est passé ça
fait plus de vingt quatre heures
maintenant ils se font pas beaucoup
d'illusions dans certains cas ils
disposent de certaines informations et
ils savent exactement à quoi s'en tenir
la prochaine entrevue que je vais vous
présenter
c'est avec quelqu'un qui est dans ce cas
là a remarqué que pendant que lui va me
raconter ça il ya des gens qui vont
peut-être entrer ici au centre
d'hébergement et qui vont apprendre
qu'on a retrouvé un de leurs proches
il ya des gens qui vont ressortir en
étant soulagés c'est pas du tout le cas
de monsieur raymond la fontaine qui lui
nous est arrivé tout à l'heure en disant
moi je sais ce qui s'est passé en tout
cas pour les gens que je recherchais
je me suis la fontaine bonjour monsieur
vous cherchez depuis hier matin
pas mal de monde qui était dans la zone
hélas ce matin votre idée pas mal fait
mon idée fait amateur
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de parler à la
télévision lorsqu'il faut savoir les
vraies choses il ya beauté tout mais
vous vous aviez vous cherchez qui hier
avant avant de vous y rendre à la
réalité qu'il est a disparu il ferait
partie des victimes
chercher mon garçon sa femme la femme de
mon autre garçon pascal marie noëlle la
secrétaire qui travaillent avec nous
autres parmi plusieurs projets puis avec
l'ampleur des feux j'étais sur les lieux
j'ai été contacté dix minutes après que
c'est arrivé mon fils christian qui
était au multi bar qui fêtait ce soir là
une de mes filles ont entendu un bruit
immense mon garçon cingo kiewit
il était avec mon autre garçon guetta
qui est mort aujourd'hui il dit faut
sortir guettant kg aujourd'hui hélas il
dit fogel chez ma femme était plus loin
dalbar question de sa femme vient à
voulait pas sortir aux usa et des
toilettes
il a pris part le breuil de sortie
quatre sorties ya vu une boule de feu
sans mener vers ho you couru tant
qu'elle était capable de brûlures de dos
lui brûler et a traversé les rues laval
la rue frontenac au complet les lumières
rased lumière et eau envie de courir
vers le quai pour sauter dans l'eau il y
avait trop de fric centenaire des armes
et ont couru à traverser la rivière ils
ont eu envie de sauter dans la rivière
il le courant est trop fort et ont viré
vers un succès d'abord et quatre en
traçant autour du pont
là après dans la rue salaberry le feu et
les a quittés ils sont virés barre puis
à ce le fut reculer ou ketter ça a été
une vague de gaz dangereuses qui ont été
chanceux j'ai marqué de laisser ma
famille au complet
mon garçon dix minutes avant pascal et
lots aux folies qui partent pour les
enfants sa femme est restée pour finir
la veillée gate pascal et est sauvé mais
deux monfils prix siens sa femme sont
sauvés de justesse le bon dieu nous a
aimés
et nous les a gardés c'était des piliers
de mai compagnie j'ai plusieurs
compagnies de monde dans la région
connaissent
et puis ma bru la femme pascale l'escat
en vain guettant laisse deux enfants on
veut garder cette nuit et puis marie
noëlle notre secrétaire ont laissé la
vie lors qu'ils me fassent pas craqué
wade retrouver j'étais sur le terrain
tout le temps s'est brûlé jusqu'au fond
de la cave
aujourd'hui on vous dire une chose je
m'en vais vous dire une chose
oui si vous allez payer un hôtel où vous
vous exposez au québec en 2013 est
tranquille
c'est comme un avion tomber sur l'autel
il n'y avait aucune raison qu'on laisse
penser une bombe atomique partir de
l'ouest qui est notre gaz qu'on veut
tuer le port cros fasse partie de ce
pays d'à qui a mis ça dans ls qui pose
chez nous ils débordent autres places au
pays de passer des bombes de même
anciennement j'ai travaillé pour le
canadien pacifique l'école et travailler
pour quinzaine cannoise puis on
travaille pour un autre film à vous dire
une chose ça répondrait vieux un lieu
hanté un train voyageurs ou de
marchandises fait pas de dommages comme
ça ça on l'a vu j'ai vu péter j'ai
marqué d'un père brûlé en annonçant mi
machine
j'avais des machines du lot parce qu'on
commence un contrôle un édit de 4
millions au centre ville qu'on attendait
qu'on attendait qu'on attendait vous
connaissez du soir on attend près sont
le pilier de la compagnie guetta qui est
le contraire de jo les techniciens qui
est actionnaire
aujourd'hui y est parti vendredi soir on
faisait un trouble deux ans sans ballack
drôle est là on a commencé à fêter sa
fille
on est arrivés en avoir partout des
femmes deux seuls pilotes ont travaillé
hier vous avez vous un enfant monsieur
si vous avez un enfant d'aller voir que
ça fait mal à tarnac
de toute évidence il ya une logique à
votre colère le vous êtes en colère je
suis pas codage pas en colère sa chute
des faits par des événements qui
auraient pu être évitées édité par ce
que nos politiciens sont supposés d'être
là pour nous protéger il nous protège
pas c'est une course à l'argent
on a des camions nous autres on a des
camions ont vérifié par la saxe après 5
go pour entretenir un camion sécuritaire
france on est toujours à la main ou des
doigts et juge en 2013 un train porte
seul puisse avoir rentré à 100 km en
ville
si ça c'est normal ça donne rien de
continuer évidemment il va y avoir
enquête on va avoir des explications au
delà de l'accident de l'erreur humaine
est dans l'erreur technique de bangor y
reste qu'il ya quand même des wagons qui
pensaient plein de pétrole chez vous
régulièrement depuis un certain temps
depuis l'avant 2 1 il y en avait pas il
y en avait pas il y avait juste et
location des choses qui prennent du
pétrole au pays lors la cave accompagne
la vie à nos besoins beaucoup d'argent
ont décidé de prendre le transport de
l'ouest vers l'est
il doit ouvrir d'autres places de penser
aux capotes civilisation sacrement
on le savait il ya deux semaines on a
les seins de sa seule injecte brisé
traite associés d'avilissement eu
déversement de pétrole
la seule pensée schmitt et à face castan
depuis mille ans pour la compagnie
proposait deux pieds tract qui
marquèrent il y avait deux qui est très
coûteux partie puis le train est passé
c'est normal qu'en 2013 quels saints go
pas retenir 100 km de tracts puis 200 km
de track trace du studio ça nous apprend
un art mais puisque nous n'ouvrons pas
travailler pour nous étouffer puis dans
sa listé compagnie d'auch avec aucune
sécurité que d aucune sécurité
j'écoutais le monsieur par les balles de
la compagnie c'est faux il y en avait
des gens alentour ont levé à la
télévision y en avait savait pas raison
parti et espoirs des gens permanent
alors qu'atari d un feu puis un feu ça
peut continuer comme on peut voir aussi
est en partie due à le salir le train 6
6 on est rendu
la partie de l'accident la partie c'est
la cause de la mort de mon garçon
oui mais le fait qu'ils avaient des
trains qui de plus en plus transporter
du pétrole qu'on ait un accident un gros
accident qu'on ait des erreurs humaines
il peut en avoir dans tout mais ils
n'ont ils pas près d'avoir partout non
mais il a vient on tente pas tous les
jours non mais il tombe
et puis je veux pas entrer dans un débat
avec vous est ce que je veux dire c'est
au bout du compte notre message et êtes
en colère mais votre frustration et
passe par le fait qu'il y avait de plus
en plus de pétrole sur les voies ferrées
hausse est au jour du pétrole jour et
nuit accéléré à des vitesses trop grande
pour la capacité des tracts la pression
la traque est ordinaire
tu es tout ordinaire avec ses dangereux
est un produit dangereux fonds
luxembourgeois plus que sa poche et nos
milan il pas mieux du village n'en pense
musulin
castany passe aujourd'hui l'âge brille
pas un village il pose partout des
villages y passe des villages de la
ville de sherbrooke
c'est pas normal on essaie nos
dirigeants faut qu'ils se réveillent qui
posent sont importés ou que c'est pas
dangereux ça voir arriver un autre fois
aujourd'hui c'est mon gars ont pu me
brûle on pense là c'est notre vie qui
est coupée la motié puis on va continuer
de ses processeurs si les gens du québec
chine de groot falloir que ça à
wrightson alors nos dirigeants y ait
écouté je prends des décisions changeant
nos décisions on peut pas revenir en
arrière mais fox a right the battle dire
une chose si je quitterai mon quart puis
charles tadjo far west legear à diablo
qui traversera pas plus loin
je te jure une chose je sens votre
frustration et je la respecte mais
permettez-moi de revenir à ce que vous
m'avez raconter quand vous êtes arrivé
vous avez gardez vos petits-enfants hier
s'est tenue au togo à partir de
maintenant il ya une nouvelle en
détresse il ya une région qui sera en
deuil vous avez vous attendiez de 4 ou 5
personnes directement
il va y avoir des dizaines dans cent ans
cette région là a besoin de toute son
énergie de
est-ce que vous la sentez cette énergie
lorsque l'on n'a pas le choix de
continuer
on n'a pas le choix de vivre notre deuil
on n'a pas le choix de continuer à vivre
son art est de manger à vos crédits auto
si c'est sûr qu'on peut bâtir la ville
la moitié de sa vie à six mois et qu'ils
doivent aussi on s'entend bien il faut
continuer à vivre mais il faut que ça
change
faut que ça change je te jure faut que
ça change fuchs et améliore faut ôter de
danger puis continuez à recommencer à
vivre nos enfants fuchs au motif que ça
fonctionne faut arrêter ces bombes lors
faut arrêter ces bons blancs nos
dirigeants qui mettent le culot autant
madame marois que monsieur à part voyons
dos on exception les gens peuvent pas
parler aujourd'hui sa première fois de
ma vie que je peux par la télévision
j'ai toujours essayé de lancer des
messages on m'a toujours arrêtée parce
qu'ils disent faut passer politique
fourbe of hope au faux pas aujourd'hui
mon boulot et ma maîtrise dont ils n'ont
plus de mère et ont pu le payer alors on
sera très lent puis dont on va vivre etc
soit pour mettre une croix dessus
c'est pas vrai il ya un gros débat sur
les pipelines dans ce moment si red et
pipelines y aurait moins de transport
envoyons rentrer au point des moyens
qu'il faut en 2013 qui veut dire on veut
pas les emmener par bateau parce que des
bateaux sont pas adéquates ont peuplé
emmené par plante toxique et font une
boîte vocale pop comme fo où il amène
par train avec les tracts qui tiennent
pas debout de ses 155 c'est raclot
marche
j'ai vécu des détails sont tous pourris
je le sais je travaille là dessus
arrêtons de taverne ex avons offert
notre histoire notre pays
sauvons les ja ch'ti vous content
d'avoir eu la chance de dire ce que vous
avez à dire est-ce que je peux terminer
en vous offrant des conneries que tu
dire qu'il soit forcé quelques
changements là dessus
faux cru que ce pétrole lampant savez je
te jure une chose faut plus que c'est
une bande et que j'en tire un mot un mot
ou qui étaient suez sont assaillis et
pillés d'un track les tresses son corps
dès lors il y avait aucune chance de
dire s'il y avait eu une chance de dire
on nettoie menée pour sortir supra le
choix de bijoux de bobines n'ayons pas
le choix ils n'ont pas le choix c'est
comme ceux ci recevraient ya it à
regarder que souris optique tire une
balle pays meurtres et la mêlée ce qu'il
fait d'appel sait combien de temps afin
que ça a été l'enfer à 20 sa part merci
beaucoup
encore une fois tu me connais
c'est le genre de témoignage j'ai bien
peur qui va malheureusement se
multiplier pas nécessairement dans cette
envergure là et pas nécessairement sur
ce ton là mais quand on vous disait que
on savait qu'il y avait des dizaines de
victimes qu'après 24 heures les proches
et les parents savaient qu'ils avaient
pu beaucoup d'espoir ils ont beau en
garde et dans certains cas comme là il y
avait moyen en recul par les histoires
et les témoignages des gens qui étaient
présents
ils ont leur idée fait que m'ont dit
même si légalement ça va prendre des
jours et des semaines avant qu'on puisse
se produire des certificats de décès
annoncés officiellement des victimes
et comme vous le voyez bien c'est son
frère là c'est le premier témoignage
malheureusement et c'est un drame si il
va y avoir pas mal